okay thank you thank you we're live are
we
yes we are thank you well good morning
everybody and welcome to
this meeting of the trafford covid 19
public engagement board
i'll start by way of introducing myself
i am councillor mike freeman
the leader has kindly appointed me as
the executive member for
covid 19 recovery and reform
and part of my duties going forward will
be chairing this
engagement board the agenda this morning
is
reasonable so we'll make track
attendances
uh with denoted tendencies uh including
offices i do have apologies this morning
from the council leader andrew weston
and from also george
devlin are there any other apologies
that i need to be made aware of
no other apologies received chair thank
you thank you thank you
uh declarations of interest are there
any decorations of interest at all
for any of the gender items at this
meeting
thank you silences golden uh the minutes
can we approve the minutes of the
meeting held on the 30th
of november clearly i wasn't present to
that meeting so i will need someone to
affirm to me that they are a true and
accurate record please
they are thank you eleanor thank you
very much indeed
um and either and under any matters
particularly arising off those minutes
at all
elena you're on mute i know i'm finally
managed it
uh the i think uh the things that we
uh had a rising are all covered in the
agenda
so we'll we'll pick them up as we go
through the agenda
well in that case ellen it makes me stay
on because we know on to item
for the update on the current code
mid-19 situation in trafford
okay thank you so um i think
uh we we are doing well in trafford i
want to start with that
and our numbers have come down but since
the end of the lockdown we're now
starting to see our numbers creeping
back
up again so i think my main message to
everybody today is
really thinking about how we manage that
risk because
from having about 20 to 25 people a day
each day traveling
testing positive last week we're up into
the mid-40s
this week um and we know from last time
that once
once it we start seeing that spread it
can happen quite quickly so
at the moment um it's
it's und you know it is about trying to
make sure we keep bringing those numbers
down and and it is really about how we
all change our behavior
um to to be just that bit more cautious
that bit more careful and the main
message i think again is about christmas
coming up
um we all want to be able to see people
over christmas we are
you know i think many of us desperately
anxious to see friends and family again
but the risk is very very real the virus
doesn't care about christmas all the
virus cares about is b
people being close enough to each other
for them to for it to be able to jump
from one person to another
and because the virus is infectious
before people have any symptoms
it's particularly important that we
think about those risks that you may not
know that you're carrying that virus
and you could absolutely inadvertently
give it to somebody
else who might be more vulnerable than
yourself equally
you can catch it from someone else um
who
you know you may you may see it is that
thing
it does this virus loves trust it loves
the fact that we trust each other it
loves the fact that we are sociable
beings
and we really have to think over the
next few weeks how we met
how we manage not to do the things that
come most naturally
to hug our closest friends our families
we have to keep that social distancing
um so i think it's really important that
at the moment we absolutely take
every possible step to keep those the
the infection rate
down and to reduce it further
um in terms of what we
should be doing over christmas and the
role of testing and i know a lot of
people have been thinking oh well if i
if i take a test
and i get a negative result then um that
will give me
i'll be i'll be more confident to go and
see people that maybe i wouldn't and
what we would say about that is that a
negative test result is a test in at a
point in time and you can come back with
a negative result while you're
incubating the disease
um so we would really stress that you
shouldn't do
anything based on a negative test result
that you wouldn't have done if you
hadn't been tested
a positive result obviously means that
you would have to self-isolate
um and that's it's just so important
that people do
do that self-isolation if you have any
symptoms please do go for a test
but a negative result is only as good as
the minute it's taken
and if you were to see somebody um you
know it's probably okay for that day but
the following day the day after
that negative test result could give you
a sense of full security
so we'd really urge people to um think
very carefully about if they do take a
test
why they're taking that test i'm getting
messages that my
internet's bad um i don't know if
anyone's got any questions about
that but it i mean people have talked a
lot about the the parallels between
um the testing and particularly the
lateral flow test the quick test
and uh pregnancy tests and i would say
well
there are some parallels to that but
similarly a pregnancy test tells you
whether or not
you're pregnant then it doesn't stop you
getting pregnant
that evening the following day and it
also
isn't accurate right at the beginning of
a pregnancy so it is that same degree of
caution that we need to be taking
all the time that absolutely keep that
social distance
and particularly really think about how
you how the risk you might pose to more
vulnerable people
particularly to parents and grandparents
i don't know if anyone has any questions
well thanks elena uh before i invite is
it
is it possibly uh a chance to talk now
about the sort of messaging
we want to get out over christmas or do
we leave that till item six
public order activity and feedback
section
shall we leave it shall we put it at
quest um
item six because then there may be some
more things that we've thought about
during the meeting
excellent okay are there any questions
at all for eleanor
i can't see any hands raised and i can't
see them
counsellor new grosh please and also
yeah count uh khan mogul as well
councillor freeman had to stand up
sorry councillor thank you i just wanted
to know if we've had the data back
for the um different efficacies between
lateral flow
and the pcr i mean there was there is a
difference between the two i just was
wondering if we know now um and if
that's guiding how we're using it
yes so we it is guiding how we're using
it as particularly
guiding how we're using the lateral flow
test for care home visitors
um so the lateral flow test is very good
at picking up people at the most
when they're at the most infectious is
less good at picking up the
um early stages and it also which has a
benefit of it
doesn't pick up that lingering positive
that we've we're seeing where people are
no longer infectious but they've had a
result
but overall a lateral flow test is less
accurate
than a pcr test which is why and as
the the slightly um you'll hear
different reports based about you know
whether it
catches you know it's 50 or 90 or
whatever
and the thing with most tests is that
the accuracy really depends on how
common the disease
is in the general pub public that you're
testing so the population you're testing
how many of them are likely to have the
disease makes a difference to how
the accuracy or what we call the
predictive value of that test
so to to give an example if you have a
test
that is has a false positive rate of
one in a hundred and you only have one
in a hundred people
in the population who might have the
disease then if you test a hundred
people you might get one
true positive and then one positive
that's picked up through that test
in very crude forms which me which so
the f
but if you had um 50 people in your 100
that had the condition
then in your testing 100 you'd find 50
of them
plus just the one false person so the
the predictive value of the test really
depends on how common the disease is in
the pub
in the co in the um population you're
testing
fortunately as our prevalence drops as
as the levels of the disease
in the population drop that means that
with the lateral flow test the
proportion of false positives may
start to increase sorry do you want to
which is we asked for confirmation yeah
i am most concerned about the false
false negatives i'm most concerned about
false negatives than i am
if someone if we get a positive and it
restricts and it's and someone doesn't
go to a care home because they think
they've got it but don't have it
i'm not so worried about that i'm
worried about the chance of
of a cohort of people getting a negative
result
and therefore doing something risky like
visiting a high-risk area that's
that's what scares me i would like to
okay no absolutely
yeah absolutely so just finishing on the
false positives what we don't want to do
is have people self-isolate that don't
need to
so what we're doing to reduce the risk
of the false positives
is um asking people who get a lateral
flow test positive result
to take a pcr test to see whether that
confirms it
they must self-isolate while they wait
for that result that is so
important absolutely crucial that people
self-isolate while waiting for that
result
but if you get a positive on the lateral
flow go for a pcr
if that's if that's positive then you
continue to self-isolate
picking up the negative point and that
is obviously a huge concern to us
because the false negative rate is also
higher on the lateral flow than on the
pcr
what we're trying to do with the in
order to reduce the risk of that
for our care home visits we're asking
people to do a pcr test first
followed by three days beforehand if
that's negative
then on the day that they visit the care
home we're asking the care home to
undertake a lateral flow test for those
visitors
so by having two lateral flow
two two tests taken both negative
that reduces the risk from about 24
in 100 10 000 down to about seven in ten
thousand so it reduces it enormously
so that's what we're doing for the care
home visits and that i think is
absolutely you know that is really
important the other thing we're doing
is we've been looking at and this really
covers the mass testing issues
uh which i'll i'll wrap up in this
before asking donna to talk more about
the may the other testing
issues but what we're trying to do in um
trafford and across greater manchester
in order to reduce the
risk of a nega a false negative from our
lateral flow tests
we're working in two ways one is
absolutely engaging with all the
national programs that are supporting
frontline workers
to take regular tests because if you're
testing yourself regularly
then the chance of a false negative
starts to become greatly released
reduced because you're testing on you
know about twice a week
so you should it should get captured
quite quickly that you shouldn't
repeatedly get a false negative
plus of course we're making sure that
people who do those tests
are properly trained to do them because
we do know there's quite a bit of user
error
in that test so so people need to be
properly supported and trained
in those testing in those tests so that
some of the key groups that we have
identified to do those regular testing
are obviously people like um
frontline nhs workers people working in
we're looking at their role in adult
social care
i think there's going to be
conversations about how these get picked
up in
in schools as well particularly for
teachers i think there's some
announcements due today on that
so we're identifying settings where it
is particularly risky for the person to
go and continue to
work if they are in if they test
positive
we're also looking at opportunities for
for example using the lateral flow tests
and outbreaks so that you can do a quick
test of everybody in
in a setting or in some high in in high
risk or high consequence settings so
where where for example if you're
working with noisy machinery and as an
outbreak we'd be able to
do a quick test of everybody and then um
and then
ideally repeat that test so i think the
key thing with the lateral flow testing
is that you should be very cautious
about a single result
and if you're making any decisions to do
something based on that negative result
we would really strongly recommend that
you do not base any decisions on a
single result
that you take a second test a couple to
three days later
to be absolutely sure that that is it is
um negative
so i think our biggest concern would be
people taking a test
single test and then thinking that's it
that's fine i'm absolutely good to go
now because really it is just as good as
the day it takes it
and it's not as accurate as we would
like
so more than one test is better
thanks elena can i invite khan then to
bring your question please
yeah um it is concerning to note that
the case is obviously going up so i've
got two
short questions one in these
statistics of increasing numbers
what is the issue with bm bame
communities are these more pronounced
in the bam communities or not and then
secondly
um i really want to know because numbers
are rising
uh the leader of the council is actually
campaigning to get
us out of tier three and into tier two
is that gonna have an effect on that
um the virus won't care if we're in tier
two or tier three
what has an effect on the virus is how
we behave and so i think even if we're
in tier two we can behave safely
and if we're in tier three we can behave
dangerously
so it's not about which tier we're in as
much as how we
how we respond to that and how we behave
if we do go into tier two
i think um the evidence is that tier two
will maintain
the levels that we're at and at a
hundred per hundred thousand it's higher
than i would like
but it's not the it's not rising at the
rates that we were earlier in in october
and before the lockdown you know where
our rates are way down from then so the
biggest impact for us i think will be
um how much people
whether people that we have to recognize
that the risk is real
but there are also economic risks so
it's always a balance between
that the dangers from the the economic
risks but
the the risks to the health service to
other so
other health services going and actually
business continuity
if our numbers go start going up again
actually we get a lot of people out of
work
because they they can't and and schools
um classes suspended teachers
self-isolating
so it becomes quite if the rates start
to go up again it does
start to become very difficult to to
operate
but tier two is is a level at which we
will be able to maintain the rates we're
at
if people absolutely abide by those
rules
and it really is about not only abiding
by the rules and understanding the rules
but also thinking about how do we
absolutely reduce our personal risk and
do not allow ourselves to be a risk to
ourselves and a risk to other people
whichever tier we're in that's the same
it's about the engagement with the
process
it's not really as much about the tier
we're in
and that's why i think this board is so
important about get getting those
messages out because
i know lots of us have seen that the
rates um you know the the rates in some
parts of london going up and it feels
very unfair that we're
we're in tier three when other areas are
are in a worse situation than us
and i agree it does feel really unfair
when you look at that
but at the same time i don't want anyone
i love
getting a virus because of something
i've done so it is about thinking about
how we how we change our behavior and
just
keep keep really trying to keep these
infection rates down
and reducing the risks
thank you another question from dorothy
please thank you
yeah it's interesting um eleanor that
you talk about the difference between
the two tests because
one of the things that we've been
experiencing is people saying that a
sometimes they can't access a test if
they need one and then there's the
um understanding what the different
tests are
people have said that they have not had
uh symptoms but they wanted to be tested
because they've been visiting loved ones
and they've not been able to get a test
is there a message that we should be
passing on to people
who are struggling to access the test
so i would say that um we are
encouraging the pcr testing to be done
just if you're symptomatic because
that's the most likely time
that it will pick up that positive
results and in fact so
i would also say that what again it's
that same point that
you have to be really careful that
having a test doesn't give you false
reassurance
so anyone who's symptomatic at the
moment should be able to get a test
um there are plenty of tests available
um and actually we've seen testing rates
very fortunately we have actually
started to see our testing rates
coming up a bit again in traffic it was
dropping and our positivity rate coming
down so again that's a really good sign
that we're actually picking up the cases
so it may be that our slight increase is
because we have been picking up more of
the cases rather than
a dramatic increase and again that's a
very good sign
but i would i would say to anyone who
thinks i'm going to take a test and then
i'm going to go and visit
visit family members i would say you
need to be very very cautious about
thinking about that
because it could give you false
reassurance if you are visiting someone
who's more vulnerable
i would very i mean at the moment and in
tier two that's still
we still can't go into people's houses
apart from that very brief period of
christmas
um so it really is stay outside even if
we go into tier two
i know a lot of us do want to be in tier
2 but again it's garden visits you know
staying outside keeping that distance so
really be very cautious about taking a
test
because it may give you don't think that
if by taking a test
you can do something that you wouldn't
have done out previously you really
shouldn't
and just picking up sorry that is the
message that i think that needs to get
out to people
because there is a i think there's a
general view that if i have a test
i can then go and visit you know and
then i i'll be fine
uh because i i i can prove that i've had
the test i think there is
that view at the moment that there's um
a lot of confidence being placed in just
that the fact that you've had a test and
not not that there's consideration being
given that you could catch copy the day
after
yes and i think i i again i people have
talked about some parallels with
pregnancy tests and i would reiterate
that i don't think any of us
would think um a woman was very sensible
if she decided that the only way she was
going to
regulate her um you know manage her
family size was by taking repeated
pregnancy tests i don't think people
would think that was a good way of
reducing your risk of getting pregnant
if you didn't want to have a baby
and similarly taking a covert test is
not a good way of stopping you getting
covered
picking up khan's point about the bme
populations i mean what we've seen
throughout
the pandemic is that some populations
have been much more severely affected
than others
and the bain population have really you
know absolutely
particularly south asian population have
had have paid a very heavy price
most of this is due to other issues
linked to deprivation
overcrowded housings lots of social
social factors social and economic
factors that really as a country
we need to be absolutely thinking about
how we address how we how we drive out
that systematic
and systemic racism that has led people
to be at higher risk from some groups
so absolutely that that we will see
discrepancies and we are seeing
discrepancies and outcomes nationally
between different groups and i think one
of the things when we're thinking about
how we build that better
is how we drive racism out of all of our
services
um so so that we can protect all of our
population equally
thank you ellen and i think yeah it
really does demonstrate it's about
personal behavior and keeping your
contacts
really to as a smaller number as
possible
as we move forward particularly over
christmas uh are there any further
questions at all
on this point on the agenda
okay we'll move on to item five the ten
point plan
and i'd invite donna to give us a verbal
update on mass testing in trafford
please thank you
thank you chair i think we've covered
quite a lot there is that a couple of
points
just wanted to make if that was possible
um we did the um
mass testing of our students at ua 92
a couple of weeks ago and that went
really well uh for a number of reasons
first of all it enabled us to
test the method so we did quite a lot of
modeling and planning
and actually getting the students
through what numbers of staff we needed
and how we manage those students
again just just for the board to be
aware um
some universities have texted the
results to students because of the sheer
numbers of them
we talked to every single student who
was tested and who got a result
just to completely reinforce those
messages to them
where that whereas they were negative at
the moment actually they needed to
maintain the behaviors that they were
doing
um throughout throughout their um
academic life
um and we really spoke to them quite you
know quite strictly about the importance
of self-isolation
um if they were positive and we talked
to them the importance about social
distancing
hand washing and masks so you know on a
one-to-one basis we really reinforce
that with
students we've been invited back to do
some further testing of the students
when they return back
um to university in mid-january which
will be delighted to support
ua 92 in doing that the second point i
just wanted to make was um
around the point that ellen are made
about care home visiting
we've done a couple of seminars now for
our care homes
who are working incredibly hard as they
always do to try and support
safe visiting whether that's pod
visiting whether that's window visiting
um and most of them now but not all of
them will have received their lateral
protests
and they have trained their staff in how
to do that and are looking
at the individual setting and how they
can make it as safe as possible
but even if people are tested for pcr
and then a lateral flow test
the visitors will still wear full ppe
and i think that's a really important
point it's
you know and the care homes as everybody
else are really keen to keep their homes
covered free and so visitors will be
expected
and will need to wear ppe when they if
they are doing an indoor visiting
as a result of wearing as a result of
the tests
so i think it's a really important point
to make on that as eleanor said the
world of testing changes all the time
there's been new lots of new national
directives which
will help us so now our supported living
settings
will also get pcr tests so they can test
their staff
and their residents and in the near
future the testing opportunities will be
extended to other vulnerable groups
we are looking at the different models
in trafford that we can offer this
um both lateral flow and pcr but i think
as eleanor pointed out the comms about
the difference between those two tests
and why people should get certain tests
and not the others it's a really
important part of this group chair
so i'll leave it at that
thank you are any questions at all for
donna
don't see any thank you very much donna
but can we move on to item 5b the mass
vaccination trafficking invite rebecca
to give us a verbal update please thank
you good morning thank you chair
um a lot has happened since the last
time i was here a couple of weeks ago
and and so the main update that i have
to um provide the board with today is
that our first
site for um community based vaccinations
through general practice
we'll get there um delivery of
vaccinations tomorrow
ready to go live on wednesday and that
is for the
um over 80s as recommended by the joint
committee on
vaccines and immunizations um so those
vaccinations will start wednesday and
conclude by
thursday so that's the main update that
i've got to um
give today thank you
what area is that rebecca is that down
in all triggers that
is ultranum health alliance network yes
so they have contacted the
over 80s within that network um chosen
as a wave one site because
um a high number of over 80s and also a
site that was up and ready to go
um in terms of the um safety and and
preparedness of the site so yes that's
ultringham
thank you for that any questions at all
for rebecca
okay i don't see it oh yes please i was
just going to
um say to rebecca my understanding is
that manchester foundation trusts were
also starting vaccination this week
um i've not had that confirmed eleanor
so if
you're i'm concentrating on the general
practice element so
if that's the position then i think
they're expecting to
manchester foundation trust is also
expecting to be going live
this week i don't know martin might know
more about the exact timing of
and that may involve so some trafford
residents may may get involved in that
martin have you have we got a start date
yet for um
mft vaccinations um like rebecca i'm not
sure if they've had their delivery
timetable confirmed or not
hopefully hopefully it will be this week
okay thank you any further questions at
all oh yeah uh councillor welton please
thank you um just uh regarding that the
vaccinations in
altering them for over 80s um how are
these uh
are these people being contacted by the
alliance network
or are they sort of somehow on the
alliance network already
um so we each practice within that
network we have a list
of the over 80s for each practice
excluding those who are in care homes
and house-bound patients until
the guidance changes and all the other
80s have been contacted via
letter to individual patients and via
text message as well
and then followed up with phone calls
thank you any further questions at all
you rebecca um so we move on to uh
5c that's the uh update and escalations
from the kobe 19
engagement coordination group verbal
update from nigel please thank you
thank you chair yes so uh there's three
things i just wanted to highlight
uh this morning uh firstly the the newly
formed uh kovitz
19 community engagement team so the
background to this
is that um as we know there's been a lot
of good work that's already been
undertaken already to ensure a robust
engagement response for kobit 19 in
trafford
this has been led through the engagement
coordination group
which is attended by a large number of
partners
who identify key engagement activities
and they meet on a weekly basis
um however it was felt that there was a
need to strengthen and build on
this engagement activity and ensure this
activity could be better coordinated
so it was agreed to establish a
dedicated
community engagement team this will uh
have four local neighborhood strategic
leads and supporting roles who will be
then really well placed to understand
the uh kind of local neighborhood needs
and behaviors
and provide two-way information flow
through those
four neighborhoods so that teams
currently being put together
i'm gonna be leading that as the program
manager and we have two of those
neighborhood leads already in place
which is nikki shaw and louise wright
and we're currently recruiting to the
other two roles and the supporting roles
so um
we'll obviously be able to give you
further updates on the work of that team
and the further work of the engagement
group going forwards um the second thing
i wanted to touch on was something
called the community champion scheme
so mhclg which is the ministry of
housing
communities and local government they
recently
announced this scheme and invited
expressions of interest for funding
a week or so ago and this is around
supporting people
showing to be most at risk from covert
19 including those
from an ethnic minority background so um
funding is available to support
activities interventions and engagement
strategies
to reduce those who have been
disproportionately affected by cobit 19
so we were keen to get a bid in for that
which we did submit
last week and that's centered around
recruiting a network of community
champions to engage with our most
vulnerable
communities and groups so um we're
waiting to get feedback on that like i
say it's only just gone in that bid last
week
but once we get some feedback and
hopefully if we're successful again
that's something we'll be able to
er feedback to the board and the third
thing i just wanted to highlight was the
um
council's web content on kobit 90 that's
been
uh recently uh redesigned and refreshed
to make it a kind of more user friendly
and accessible to residents and
businesses
with various advice and guidance on
covert 19 so
that's now gone live last week and
there's kind of various headings such as
the restrictions in trafford
information for residents businesses how
to get financial support
food and medical support testing
information for schools etc so that
that should hopefully be a lot more
user-friendly for all our residents and
businesses
and we'll also be further redefining
that for example we want to get some
uh regular updates on data on the
website as well so those are the three
uh key points chair i wanted to make
this morning
uh thank you nigel regarding the website
i've looked at it and looked at it this
morning
and i know martin dillon's on on on this
meeting
um i have afraid to say that none of the
links off the web page
worked this morning so you clicked on a
link to get some information
and pages not found so somebody could
have a look at that for us today
make sure it's up and running i'd be
very grateful um
there's some good stuff there nigel
you've mentioned particularly around
the bid we've made are there any
questions at all for nigel from anyone
i don't see any uh which brings us then
on to
uh item 5d and we have a paper that was
sent around
to assume everybody has a chance to read
from the enforcement subgroup the
updated escalations
from that group is there anything you
want to add to the paper nigel at all
yes uh so uh helen i thought you can't
beat here today but just in terms of
like i said hopefully everyone's had a
chance to to look through the report
um the issue is with the report it's
it's it's kind of like a week behind as
we know with the structuring of the
meetings which i know we're possibly
looking at but
um i think just just as the report
highlights
um there's been a lot of activity
focused around licensed premises where
we've seen
generally good compliance uh
around austrian market again which has
been busy
but businesses found to be complying
with uh but with some further advice
has been given just to improve improved
measures where they can be
at the traffic center actually expect
that's been a focus of activity
um we had an issue with a driving event
a week or so ago but that was um
addressed immediately uh by the operator
once we highlighted the issues there
we had the support of raf v8 shows for a
few days
um over the last couple weeks they've
been focusing on
uh visits to gyms and where we've had
some complaints around classes taking
place and obviously gyms are allowed to
be open should
just be individuals rather than classes
taking place
and also we've been doing some follow-up
visits to
uh beauty and hair premises so those
have been the focus of activity
on the enforcement side and one thing
just worth mentioning as well is around
on
residential premises uh we do get
reports from
a number of different areas in terms of
um
where there's gatherings uh and this is
managed by ourselves jointly and the
gmp and the community safety as well as
the social housing provider
so what's been encouraging is that the
number of reports that we had i think
they've been
around some weeks as high as 60 reports
a week but
the previous week showed it was as low
as 11 so that was that was encouraging
thank you nigel can i just say that in
my previous role on the executive i did
have
for regulatory services and i just want
to place on record my thanks
to our environmental health teams to the
licensed officers
uh i have worked absolutely you know
right throughout this pandemic
under great pressure and i'm very
pleased to see
that we're actually being supported now
by some raf environmental health
officers
um and they'll be trying to recruit even
further but i know that there's been
some fantastic work
done by by your team nigel and
collaborating of course with with
eleanor's team
and i'm very grateful for the work that
they've done right across the board
thank you
are there any questions at all for nigel
on that report
i'd just like to echo the thanks to the
environmental health team they have been
absolutely amazing throughout
i mean people have talked a lot about
public health in this but the
environmental health team have had so
much work to do and they have done it so
well
so constructively they've engaged so
well with businesses
and um you know just absolute credit to
nigel's
team they are brilliant
thank you elena um which brings us on to
um e the update from the age world board
then i invite
louise wright to give that verbal update
please thank you louise
thank you chair and morning everyone
just a brief update to let you all know
you may have seen it come out in
press release um that we are
campaigning for um older people's voices
so
it does fit very well with the bit that
nigel's just mentioned but this is
specifically around
older people um so really we're looking
for
anyone who can kind of raise awareness
really champion the cause
and you know make sure that community
voices
are really heard obviously you know this
age group has been
um impacted by kobe so you know it's
really important we're looking for
people across a range of interests
who can really be that champion for
their community
so hopefully a press release will be
going out in the messenger
um over the next week and i can pop the
link
to um the press release on the council
site
um inviting people to come forward into
the chat box
so it's just a brief update from me
thank you louise any questions at all
for louise
i don't see any right well that brings
us on to
uh item six public engagement board
activity and feedback
um we don't like to start us off on this
one please
is any well if i could start then
we talked at the very start about the
messaging we need to get out
and i've had a chat with two of my exec
colleagues joanne harding and jane
slater did some
messaging for us around mental health
and well-being
earlier on during the pandemic and they
if if we prepare some pointers for them
they are prepared to do the same again
around the sort of messaging we want to
get out to our residents around
christmas time so for joanne harding
who's adult social care
we'll be looking at visiting your loved
ones in care homes
for james slater's health and well-being
would be the general messages we need to
get out about
behavior of our individual behavior
keeping your contacts to a minimum um
and that sort of thing and i was
wondering if anyone thought there's a
specific
needed tool for a message around
children as well i don't know but
uh ellen would you like to comment on i
think
i was just about to say um i was going
to bring helen in to talk about the work
that's going on with schools and parents
so helen do you want to talk about
some of the work that you've been doing
and then perhaps um donna can talk a
little bit about some of the care
homework as well
oh yeah so in reference to children
we've um sent
letters out to through like a joint
signed letter
with eleanor jill mcgregor and the head
teacher and it's gone out from all
schools in trafford
thinking about um the rules at christmas
but also about keeping
safe and kind of the bigger covered
picture i guess rather than just
the the covered at the christmas period
uh we've also
produced a teaching resource that's gone
to all schools and it's for children
from year five and up and we're asking
teachers to use this with all
classes and assemblies and form time and
it talks through
um covert but actually not about the
rules but why we do what we do just so
young people can
understand why they need to to do what
they do basically
and then there's a little learning
challenge on there as well about
drafting a list of their own contacts so
they can understand who their contacts
are
so we've tried to do it in kind of a
behaviour change learning approach
rather than just a finger wagging um
rules approach because we know that
young people don't listen to typical
well they do
but you know we just have to think about
it in their terms don't we so there's
lots going on with children and
uh you know really asking schools to
send out strong messages around um
christmas and working with families to
engage them to be covered secure
thanks
uh thank you helen uh any questions
arising out of what helen's had to say
anybody at all
or then i should invite donna to
continue
thank you chair um i think care homes um
obviously councillor harding feels
that's a very important area
and um diane might um confirm this with
me but when we've been working with care
homes
they're trying to do direct
communications with their visitors which
is lovely i mean one of the care homes
was telling me that you know they have
an hour-long conversation with each of
the
to understand what the expectations are
what what you can do and what you can't
do
i think um councillor harding would also
be really keen to support the older
residents
not necessarily in care homes and the
work that louise was talking about is
really important
there isn't a chair in terms of the
wider older population
i think the other point that we just we
haven't mentioned yet is about the
changes in terms of self-isolation
which came out i think it was friday
this week
so self-isolation periods are reduced
from 14 days to 10 days
so that's another message i think in the
whole range of messages we need to be
clear about as well cancer
well thank you and i do agree with you
it's about
there's so many different messages we
could get out there it's about getting
the actual
the right balance um uh i do think that
it would be useful if we could use both
uh joanna and jane who are more than
willing to
to to set up and it's a question of
getting those messages to them and
letting
play around it and then then recording
for both our facebook page youtube
you know our youtube page and also on
social media
on twitter um so that's very useful
eleanor i think um i think one of the
things i would really love to come out
of this group is if everybody on this
group
and the people that they represent if
you like so um
whether you're a council of the other
people in your in your party
the other councillors but if your
voluntary sector the messages that we
can send out about
really um it's it's absolutely now that
we have to
you know whether we're in tier three or
tier two it really doesn't matter
it'll be lovely if we are in tier two um
but being in tier two
means we still have to stay with the
same behaviors in terms of
how we manage that risk so it's it's not
relying on things like tests to do
anything for us it's thinking about our
personal responsibility and our personal
risk assessments
and how we manage that and how we
support people with understanding those
risks
so i think if everybody here could
could make sure that those messages get
relayed through your organizations
through your twitter through any contact
that you're having
that um you know it is about
winter is a really difficult time we're
likely to be
more you know being indoors being in a
noisy environment
um being being in a crowded place all of
those are things that
um the virus just likes that's what it
you know that's what it likes it likes
humans
and it likes humans who stay close
together and if you're in a noisy place
your voice you know you're likely to
talk more loudly so you'll spread
your your um the any droplets are likely
to spread further
um so it is that just maintaining the
hand washing
the the wearing the mask avoiding places
that look
look difficult and if you you know
wherever possible meet people outside
um and just try and try and keep people
safe that way
and really really thinking about that
over over christmas and not relying on
anything external
really to help you it is about how we
all help ourselves
keep each other safe
thank you i think it's very very clear
um
anything further on this section on the
activity and feedback at all from anyone
don't see that which brings us to any of
the business and i think we want to talk
about meeting times don't we elena
i'll let you go with that oh um
monday mornings um for various reasons
they're a terrible time for
for us um because the rate you know
fortunately at the moment with our rates
being relatively stable it's
it's less of an issue but you know we're
playing catch up with some of the data
so we can't get the data out to you
um you know the data you've had on
friday is always a bit out of date by
the time you come
so we were wondering about moving it to
a midweek meeting because that gives us
more time to prepare for the meeting
rather than having it on a monday
morning
um we want to keep to fortnightly for
for the
for a while while we just you know
certainly i think to get us through the
winter
because while the vaccine the vaccine
being in place is
absolutely fantastic um it is going to
take a little while for us all to get
through you know to get the numbers of
people vaccinated that need to be
vaccinated um so it is that
really how do we work all together
to keep um get us through to april
where you know the better weather will
be coming hopefully and and things will
start being easier again
but it's just thinking about how we how
we how we keep strong really in trafford
how we do what i know traffic people can
do really well which is uniting against
against this virus and against the risks
it poses to us
so we're suggesting continuing having
fortnightly meetings but probably me
moving to perhaps a wednesday in order
to get
um a bit more time for the preparation
for the meeting and making sure
everything's a little bit more timely
thanks helena let's chair uh i'm
flexible i support that i think midweek
does make a lot more sense
um is that
i take it that's suitable for everybody
else is it a midweek meeting
don't see any objections to that oh
dorothy do you want to come
in
yeah midweek meeting does suit me to be
honest for all the reasons that ellen
has mentioned
wednesday's great thank you thanks to
that confirmation
um so ellen it looks like if you want to
suggest some dates but can i suggest now
that
we look to meet again with the christmas
period coming up
in the full the second week of january
for that meeting is that okay with
everybody
i don't see anyone objecting so if we
if we're working for the middle of the
week the second week in january i'll
wait for the dates to be
circulated out by sorry through you um
so that would be the wednesday the 13th
of january are we saying uh to keep it
at 10 o'clock at 10 o'clock start
eleanor i think that's that's fine i
think
unless i will unless if people have any
um difficulties with that if you contact
fabiola or me and we'll make sure that
um if that's if that's very problematic
for people for other reasons we'll we'll
look for another time but
10 o'clock start on on the um on a
wednesday seems better to me
uh we will also um send you around
um if anything what i would like to do
with this group as well
is if we see anything where we're
worried about the data or good news as
well actually i'd like to make sure we
consent we will send that round to you
because it's now um we've now got a
month well four weeks before we meet
again
and a lot can happen in that time i know
the council's closed for some of that
but we will
we will probably try to get some
messaging out to you um
before the council closes its um
closes for christmas and um in that week
when we come back after the afternoon
year as well
just so that people are aware of what's
happening so that you're you're up to
date with any messaging you're wanting
to give to
to people that you're in touch with
that yesterday hey diana just wanted to
say we're not closed
the building is closed the council's not
closed and
months which just felt available 10
years hasn't it so a big thank you
thanks for that time i'd like to echo
what you just said there
again you know um i think a lot of our
staff have gone
uh i've gone the extra mile and
i'm very you know personally as a
counselor i am very proud
of what we've done at trafford council
throughout this pandemic
and uh and i know how frazzled some of
our staff are
i hope that some of them do get a chance
to have a bit of a arrest
respite over christmas it's no more than
they deserve but you're absolutely right
diane the council will continue to
function
over that period we certainly are not
closed
um is there anything any other business
at all anyone wants to bring
can i thank you all for your attendance
um really enjoyed sharing this meeting
this morning
and we're all being well we'll see you
again on the 13th of
january at 10 a.m thank you very much
for your attendance
and have a happy christmas everybody if
i don't see any of your tours
have a lovely christmas thank you